[Music]
good morning Hank
hi good morning good morning
I have a sigh good morning Hank Juhi yes
will you say good morning Hank I'm gonna
make good morning Hank above 700 library
where you say boys just good morning
Hank not above 700 librarian tank but
alongside with them that was a pretty
great good morning Hank Hank a lot of
great things happened at the American
Library Association conference this
weekend and if you're wondering why
you're looking at this very strange shot
instead of any of those great things
like me hanging out with Judy Blume or
me going to a lot of fun parties it's
because I accidentally taped over all
that stuff with 30 minutes of this stuff
ah stupid
fortunately you will get to listen to me
harangue a reader are you a dumper no
your only friends cuz he wants you back
now it was meat relax
never mutual in fact pretty much the
only things I have footage of our
nerdfighter Cynthia award-winning the
Newbery Honor for her book rules and the
Printz award reception on Monday night
we're going to do a phone call it was
father Stevens happen to ask for the
good news
and you get again next Stacy John's
brother Andy toasted with
I think a la convención is always fun
but this one was particularly fun
because it was so Hank tastic everywhere
I went people are like hey you're Hank
Green's brother and I was like yeah I
also write books and they're like right
but you're Hank Green's brother for
different people asked me if I knew your
phone number and I was like he's my
brother
yes I know his phone number and they
said can I have it and I said no people
kept telling me how cute you are and how
funny you are and how much they like you
so Hank if you like young adult
literature so much I would encourage you
to write some of it because you're bound
to be an instant hit all the prints
features were great Markus Zusak Tobin
Anderson geunyang and Sonya Hartnett all
were wonderful I don't know how I did
but here's the funniest snippet I'll let
you judge whenever her sister got
married a man I was trying an Aryan
story with one of my own this is
entitled I see the magic library
conference in New Orleans I would come
farm at Brandon's party during eating a
cosmic dandy when I happen to cross one
passed out from sprawled across without
carpet hair assisted spill Trinity one
hand and again promising personal Hank
I'll see you tomorrow